pressekonferenz nach der zulassung des
bundeskanzlers mit dem regierungschefin
und regierungschefs der länder ich darf
in dem bundeskanzler oder schulz den
vorsitzenden der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
nordrhein westfalens ministerpräsident
hendrik wüst und die regierende
bürgermeisterin von berlin
franziska die feier begrüßen und wie
üblich beginnt der bundeskanzler
meine damen und herren wir befinden uns
in einem ganz besonderen tag der
pandemie
wir können zuversichtlich nach vorne
schauen als wir das die letzten wochen
konnten wir haben in den letzten wochen
und monaten entscheidungen getroffen die
dazu beigetragen haben dass deutschland
im verhältnis zu seinen nachbarländern
viel besser durch die aktuelle
virus infektionswelle gekommen ist die
infektionen sind bei uns später erst
gestiegen auch die infektion die mit der
omicron variante zusammenhängen der
scheitelpunkt ist mittlerweile wohl
erreicht alle anzeichen die wir haben
sprechen dafür dass genau zu dem
zeitpunkt unsere zusammenkunft wie
vorhergesehen das gelungen ist und wir
können davon ausgehen dass wenn alles so
bleibt wie wir das gegenwärtig
voraussehen können wir in den nächsten
wochen eine stetig verbesserte situation
haben was gelungen ist dass es weniger
männer und frauen gibt die auf den
intensivstationen behandelt werden
müssen als das ohne alle unsere
maßnahmen der fall gewesen wäre das
gelungen ist ist wie gesagt dass die
infektion geringer gestiegen sind und
deshalb können wir glaube ich sagen dass
wir mit unseren maßnahmen erreicht haben
was wir wollten gesundheit und leben der
bürgerinnen und bürger zu schützen einen
lock down zu vermeiden und mit dem dann
aber doch betroffenen kontakt beschränkt
und dazu beizutragen dass genau diese
situation von uns jetzt festgestellt
werden kann die wir haben also ein gutes
zeichen die letzten wochen und monate
haben die länder und der bund gemeinsam
offenbar die richtigen entscheidungen
getroffen
das ist jetzt auch die grundlage dafür
dass wir
optimistische perspektiven auf machen
können und für die zeit bis zum
frühlingsanfang jetzt in drei schritten
stück für stück einen großen teil der
beschränkung die gegenwärtig noch in
deutschland gelten zurücknehmen dazu
haben sich die länder und der bund
miteinander verabredet und wollen das
koordiniert zwischen den ländern und dem
bund in den nächsten tagen und wochen
auch stück für stück vollziehen ich
halte das für einen guten fortschritt
denn es geht ja vielen bürgerinnen und
bürgern sowie mir irgendwie haben wir
nach all diesen langen zwei jahren zwei
jahren auch mal
verdient dass es irgendwie wieder besser
wird und es sieht ein bisschen danach
aus dass wir genau das auch vor uns
haben wir dürfen bei all dem optimismus
und der zuversicht die wir hier
verzeichnen nicht unvorsichtig werden
deshalb muss man auch klar sagen die
pandemie ist eben noch nicht vorbei die
infektionszahlen sind eben hoch und wir
dann sehen jetzt nur dass sie wohl
demnächst untergehen
und deshalb gilt auch immer noch dass
wir alle
noch überzeugen müssen die sich bisher
nicht haben impfen lassen impfung hilft
und schützt am meisten vor den folgen
der infektion
und dass wir jetzt im verhältnis zu
vielen anderen besser durch die omikron
welle gekommen sind liegt natürlich auch
daran dass wir viele geimpfte haben wenn
auch nicht genug und dass sehr viele
gepustet sind im vergleich zu anderen
land ziemlich viele und dass beides muss
fortgesetzt werden dass wir wollen wir
jetzt und auch in den nächsten wochen
und monaten weiter machen mit impfung
erstimpfung zweitimpfung und
auffrischungsimpfung und wir wissen alle
dass sie diese entscheidung für sich
treffen der pigs hilft eben
außerdem wissen wir dass wir vorsorge
treffen müssen für die zeit wenn der
frühling angefangen hat und all die
maßnahmen die bisher an beschränkung
ergriffen haben überwiegend nicht mehr
gelten dass das was notwendig ist dann
auch noch ergriffen werden kann als
entscheidung der länder und der dort der
zuständigen behörden das gilt für maske
und abstandhalten bestimmten rahmen und
viele viele andere maßnahmen
die sind hier in dem beschluss
aufgeschrieben und ich zusammen mit der
bundesregierung und allen anderen werde
mich dafür verwenden dass entsprechend
dieses beschlusses in den
gesetzgebungsprozess
der jetzt einsetzt im bundestag auch
diese anliegen für die zeit nach dem
frühlingsbeginn und nach auslaufen der
meisten maßnahmen
aufgegriffen werden dass
handlungsfähigkeit erhalten bleibt und
wir vorbereitet sind für das was uns
begegnen kann denn ich habe es gesagt
die pandemie ist noch nicht vorbei und
es kann deshalb die nächste variante um
die ecke kommen und uns vor ganz neue
herausforderungen stellen und dann
müssen wir das tun können und das ist
auch richtig wir hatten heute auch
erneut
ein vertreter des expertengremiums dabei
ja uns sorgfältig geschildert hat dass
dort der rat ist und er ist auch genauso
wir können das mit den öffnungszeiten
die wir jetzt machen wagen wir müssen
vorsorge treffen für die zeit danach das
gilt insbesondere für maske und abstand
und manche anderen maßnahmen und wir
müssen weiter für das impfen werben und
genau das wollen wir alles machen
gestartet wenn auch die persönliche
bemerkung dass ich glaube dass wir trotz
der zuversicht trotz der tatsache dass
wir jetzt in den frühling hinein kommen
wo wir viele beschränkungen hinter uns
lassen und sache besser wird nicht
vergessen dürfen dass es auch den
nächsten herbst und winter gibt und
deshalb bleibt es richtig nicht nur
weiter fürs impfen zu werden sondern
auch die gesetzgebungs maßnahmen im
hinblick auf eine allgemeine impfpflicht
vorzubereiten sie wird genau dann
notwendig sein wenn das wetter wieder
kälter wird wenn die zeit später dunkler
wird und wenn die infektion wieder
zunehmen kann und das ist die aufgabe
die wir dann auch noch von zahlen dank
der vielen dank wir stehen in der tat an
einer stelle an dem wir
verantwortungsvoll und vorausschauend
eröffnungs perspektiven schaffen können
und rechts eingriffe zurücknehmen können
wir müssen dabei öffnungen und
achtsamkeit miteinander verbinden es
besteht derzeit grund zur hoffnung dass
sich die omikron welle langsam
zurückziehen wird eine überlastung des
grund des gesundheitssystems ist aus
sicht der experten derzeit nicht zu
befürchten
und deswegen befinden wir uns jetzt in
einer neuen phase der pandemie das heißt
öffnungen werden möglich die rücknahme
von grundrechtseingriffen möglich aber
wir müssen eben auch in dieser phase 18
bleiben das bedeutet vor allen dingen
das verantwortungsvolle öffnungs
perspektiven verbunden sein müssen mit
einem guten basisschutz wenn der
bundestag nicht aktiv handelt laufen ab
dem 20 märz alle schutzmaßnahmen aus
unfall ins schlicht alle maßnahmen die
wir bisher noch keinen weg an dem ihr
richtet sich aber nicht nach dem
kalender
wir dürfen deshalb nicht alles
hopplahopp über bord werfen was sich in
den letzten monaten bewährt hat uns ja
auch zu dem von bundeskanzler gerade
zurecht agenten erfolgen geführt hat
alle länder sind sich deshalb einig dass
wir einen basisschutz brauchen um die
öffnungen abzusichern auch über den
frühlingsanfang hinaus der verhindert
dass die infektionszahlen dann wieder
steigen und im falle eines ansteigendes
der und infektionszahlen sofort auch
verfügbar ist aus sicht der länder
brauchen wir deshalb aus der sammlung
der bewährten schutzmaßnahmen besondere
masken pflicht
abstandsregeln und jene konzepte test
und zumindest die möglichkeit in
besonders gefährdeten bereichen
testpflicht und nachweispflichten
vorzusehen hier geht es immer darum dass
wir eine rechtsgrundlage dafür brauchen
die man dann natürlich nur wenn sie
wirklich
notwendig ist
einige dieser möglichkeiten brauchen wir
im übrigen auch für einen stabilen schul
und kita betrieb die länder haben die
bundesregierung gebeten für den
basisschutz eine sichere rechtsgrundlage
zu schaffen damit wir eben jederzeit
handlungsfähig wären wenn notwendig auch
wenn der bundeskanzler den katalog in
summe jetzt nicht förmlich mittragen
konnte bin ich ihnen doch dankbar auch
für seine gerade getätigte aussage dass
er sich innerhalb der koalition im bund
persönlich für diese vorstellung der
länder einsetzen will wir haben respekt
vor den mehrheiten hier im parlament
aber lassen wir auch sagen das hat sich
in den letzten monaten der pandemie
immer bewährt wenn bund und länder eng
zusammengearbeitet haben auch wenn es
hier und da mal schwierig wurde und das
ist auch beim basisschutz wichtig
brauchen verlässlichkeit und klarheit in
der pandemie politik das gilt auch bei
fragen wie viele monate ein mensch sein
genesenen status hat das hin und her in
den letzten wochen war nicht gut es hat
viele menschen verunsichert und das muss
beendet werden solche entscheidungen
können auch nicht einfach auf der
homepage vom rk ii das sich ansonsten
sehr schätze kommuniziert werden ohne
dass irgendjemand da vorher nochmal
drauf guckt deshalb sollen die regeln
zum gelesenen staates in zukunft wieder
in einem geordneten verfahren der
rechtssetzung
erfolgen geht darum dass die regeln
praktikabel und umsetzbar sind deswegen
müssen dabei auch die länder die länder
rechte gewahrt sein achtsamkeit heißt
auch öffnungen zwischendurch zu
überprüfen wir haben ja die schritte
gemacht damit zwischendurch 14 tage zeit
ist in denen man schauen kann und so
haben wir es auch
verabredet in beide richtungen schauen
kann ob die maßnahmen lage angemessen
sind klarer kurs ist sehr wichtig die
öffnungen sind
richtig ich hätte mir aber gewünscht
dass wir uns zu der frage
gehen wir den nächsten schritt oder
müssen wir vielleicht umkehren auch
termin nicht konkret verabredet hätten
wenn es wäre nicht klug jetzt zu lockern
und dann ist einfach weiterlaufen zu
lassen sind selbst unterwegs sichtbar
wird das vielleicht ein bisschen tempo
rausnehmen wichtig wären wir müssen
achtsam bleiben um die ersten schritte
der öffnungen nicht zu gefährden wir
müssen achtsam bleiben weil gerade
besonders schutzbedürftige personen
gruppen von schweren verläufen betroffen
sind und auch in zukunft betroffen sein
können wir müssen achtsam bleiben weil
in teilen deutschlands die ältere
bevölkerung nicht über einen so hohen
impfschutz verfügt die in anderen
ländern
und deshalb möchte ich hier auch nochmal
ausdrücklich sagen neben den basisschutz
muss weiterhin gelten impfen impfen
impfen dass die zweite leitplanke für
die eröffnungsauktion und für die
eröffnungs schritte wir müssen weiterhin
gemeinsam daran arbeiten die eben
flecken zu schließen auch mit blick auf
dem herbst der expertenrat hat uns dazu
auch klare hinweise gegeben dass damit
zu rechnen ist dass die pandemie eben
nicht vorbei ist das impfen bleibt der
richtige weg raus aus der pandemie und
um menschenleben zu schützen wir reden
ja viel über diejenigen die das ganze
land spazierengehen filme über die reden
die zum impfen gehen ist ein starker
beitrag zur solidarität und freiheit für
alle und darf deshalb sage ich all denen
die sie haben ihn verlassen und sich
jetzt vielleicht ist auch kurzfristig
überlegen ganz herzlichen dank dafür
heute ist ein wichtiger schritt und auch
ein neuer schritt gegangen worden ein
dreisprung den wir vereinbart haben in
drei schritten eben vorzugehen für die
öffnungs perspektiven das ist etwas was
sehr erwartet wird in der bevölkerung
und was ich auch glücklicher weise durch
die aktuell abflachende omikron welle
und die tatsache dass wir den
scheitelpunkt erreicht beziehungsweise
überschritten haben auch rechtfertigen
deshalb ist es notwendig das eben in dem
moment wo die lage sich entspannt wo die
situation in den krankenhäusern auf der
intensivstation
beherrschbar ist auch in einen anderen
bereichen der kritischen infrastruktur
das will ich ganz deutlich sagen denn
darum ging es uns immer die kritische
infrastruktur im gesundheitsbereich und
darüber hinaus zu sichern wenn diese
situation beherrschbar ist und sich
entspannt dann ist es notwendig auch
schritte der verhältnismäßigkeit zu
gehen schritte der rücknahme von
einschränkungen schritte von öffnungen
und lockerung und dies
verantwortungsvoll zu tun das ist schon
deutlich geworden deshalb ist heute für
den schritt eins eben die lockerung bei
privaten zusammenkünften beschlossen
worden auch das was sie jetzt bei der
regel im einzelhandel betrifft das ja
schon in vielen bundesländern auch im
vorgriff der heutigen ministerpräsident
konferenz umgesetzt oder vorbereitet
worden ist die rücknahme von 2g im
einzelhandel und die ersetzung dieser
regelung durch die ffw 2 michael eine
sehr diskutierte maßnahmen die heute
beschlossen worden ist generell als
regelung im ersten schritt und daneben
in schritt zwei ab dem vierten märz die
lockerungen und den dreijährigen für
gastronomie und hotellerie lockerungen
für diskotheken und clubs und andere
tanz lustbarkeiten aber auch weitere
öffnungs perspektiven und erweiterte
perspektiven für die großveranstaltungen
und dann eben mit dem 20 märz dann der
wegfall der tiefgreifenden
schutzmaßnahmen das sind schritte auf
die wir uns sehr sehr einvernehmlich
verständigt haben es ist gut dass das
stufenweise geschieht das eben nicht von
einem tag auf den anderen dinge
verändert werden sondern dass wir jetzt
einen klaren plan haben einen klaren
plan für die nächsten vier wochen klare
perspektiven die wir auch kommunizieren
wollen und die nachvollziehbar sind für
die bevölkerung und daneben aber auch
dass herr kollege wüster dargestellt die
perspektive über den 20 märz hinaus wenn
wir uns jetzt auf diese wegstrecke auf
diese reise begeben hin zu mehr öffnung
hin zur rückkehr in die normalität dann
ist es wichtig dass wir auch über den 20
märz hinaus den
sprichwörtlichen sany kasten im
kofferraum haben der eben sichert das
wenn ein notfall geschieht wir sofort
handlungsfähig sind und das ist ein
großes anliegen der länder dass heute
auch geäußert worden ist die
handlungsfähigkeit im notfall die
handlungsfähigkeit wenn wir einen
ausbruchsgeschehen haben die
handlungsfähigkeit in bestimmten
situationen eben klar zu sagen es gibt
regelungen für die maske es gibt
regelungen für die tests und es gibt
auch regelungen für nachweispflichten
getestet genesen geimpft das wird nötig
sein als basis instrumentarium dass wir
sehr zügig diese möglichkeiten auch
haben und regional bezogen dann diese
schritte auch gehen können und mit
diesem seien die kosten im kofferraum
können wir uns optimistisch
verantwortungsvoll verhältnismäßig und
wirksam auf den weg machen und wir
können diese schritte diese wichtigen
perspektiven nicht nur aufzeigen sondern
sie auch umsetzen und deshalb ist heute
wirklich ein guter tag für
die perspektive der kommenden wochen ich
bin sehr froh darüber dass wir diese
beschlüsse so gefasst haben es wird
jetzt darum gehen dass der umfang der
schutzmaßnahmen auch dann im bundestag
durch bundesgesetzgebung entsprechend
geregelt wird dass wir eben ein mindest
instrumentarium nach dem zwanzigsten
märz auch in den ländern unmittelbar in
der haben das wird jetzt geschehen wir
begrüßen das sehr und ich glaube dass
wir mit diesen klaren regelungen jetzt
auch den verschiedenen branchen in der
wirtschaft gerade denen die besonders
gelitten haben auch unter den
einschränkungen heute hier auch ein ganz
klares zeichen für den aufbruch für den
neustart senden können rückenwind für
die kommende und beginnende
frühjahrssaison und dass wir auch und
das will ich auch noch mal ganz
besonders betonen die kinder und
jugendlichen im blick haben diejenigen
die jetzt natürlich unter diesen
einschränkungen auch viele würden
hinnehmen mussten das hat die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz heute auch
noch einmal deutlich gemacht mit einem
teil der beschlussfassung dass eben
gerade die bedingungen für die kinder
und jugendlichen eben für uns wichtig
sind und dass in den kommenden folge
schritten die in den ländern umgesetzt
werden natürlich auch und gerade die
folgen und die wirkung der
einschränkungen für kinder und
jugendliche berücksichtigt werden und
das bei allen öffnungs und
lockerungsschritte neben alle
altersgruppen gleichermaßen zu
berücksichtigen sind das finde ich
wichtig und deshalb wird es sicherlich
auch zur frage der schulsituation der
kita situation in den ländern darüber
hinausgehende regelung geben dass es ja
in der mpk nicht gegenstand die
einzelregelungen dafür zu treffen aber
vorsorge zu treffen mit eben dem
basisschutz paket auch für den bereich
der kitas und der schulen darauf haben
wir uns verständigt dass das genau so
eben in diesen bereichen gilt und
insofern glaube ich dass wir hier heute
ein klares signal für die nächsten vier
wochen setzen können für den ablauf aber
auch darüber hinaus vereinbarung
getroffen haben wie ermöglicht werden
kann dass die länder die notwendigen
handlungsmöglichkeiten auch über den
märz hinaus dann haben denn die
sieben worte neigung die erste
wortmeldung hat michael fischer von dpa
vielen dank herr bundeskanzler zunächst
eine verständnisfragen zu den
großveranstaltungen
werden da nach dem 20 märz auch noch
teilnehmer beschränkungen möglich sein
oder im klartext werden ab dem 20 märz
tatsächlich die fußballstadien in
deutschland wieder bis zum letzten platz
gefüllt werden können und dann würde
mich interessieren welche auswirkungen
der lockerung sie auch die debatte über
die impfpflicht
sehen
befürchten sie dass eine normalisierung
des öffentlichen lebens die akzeptanz
für diese impfpflicht möglicherweise
beschränken könnte also sie werden in
den betrug finden dass wir nach dem mit
dem frühlingsanfang uns nach
dem zwanzigsten auch noch basis
schutzmaßnahmen hand als
handlungsmöglichkeit aufrechterhalten
wollen aber nicht als standard rede
sondern als das was dann ist das ist ja
doch jetzt die mutige zuversichtliche
optimistischen prognose die 16 länder
und die bundesregierung gemeinsam abend
dass wir es wagen können tatsächlich das
meiste zu öffnen trotzdem brauchen wir
danach noch die möglichkeit zu handeln
wenn das passiert und wie das gemacht
wird darüber wird jetzt konkret im
einzeln gesprochen und dazu stehen hier
einzelne vorschläge dem beschluss drin
und die rechtliche grundlage soll
rechtzeitig vor dem zwanzigsten
existieren aber das gebe ich ihnen gerne
sagen das meiste wird dann so seien
es da kaum beschränkungen sind und
abstand und masken werden die
wichtigsten regeln seien die wir haben
ein paar andere werden wir noch brauchen
und vor allem situativ brauchen also
wenn dann plötzlich ein ausbruch da ist
wenn in einem landkreis eine situation
entsteht wo zum beispiel eine großes
infektionsgeschehen ist da muss man was
tun und diese instrumente möglich zu
machen darüber findet jetzt gesetzgebung
stadt und die wollen wir auch
rechtzeitig abschließend vor dem
zwanzigster märz da war noch eine zweite
frage im pflichten
nein die impfpflicht es notwendig für
den nächsten herbst und winter das habe
ich gesagt wir werden jetzt
nicht noch eine neue variante alles
durcheinanderbringt wenn da nicht noch
irgendein andere variante des virus um
die ecke kommt werden wir jetzt
tatsächlich an frühling erleben und ein
sommer in dem die meisten beschränkungen
die wir haben unseren alltag nicht mehr
beeinträchtigen und das ist auch gut und
wenn ich das mal sagen darf gibt habe
ich für uns drei und bürgerinnen und
bürger dieses landes sowie für alle
anderen wir sehen uns auch danach dass
das so ist und
gleichzeitig müssen wir vorsichtig
bleiben deshalb brauchen wir die
möglichkeit was du tun wenn es notwendig
wird und masten werden auch danach noch
eine rolle spielen
und deshalb brauchen wir natürlich auf
die vorbereitung auf den herbst und
winter und dazu ist das mit der
impfpflicht unverändert wichtig das will
ich noch mal festhalten die einigkeit
die 16 länder und der bundeskanzler in
dieser frage haben besteht fort wir
finden zu 17 das ist richtig ist und da
macht dafür und ich bin auch
zuversichtlich
als nächstes auf der liste habe ich
andreas künast
vielen dank eine frage zum genesenen
status herr bundeskanzler indem sie dem
robert koch institut die zuständigkeit
jetzt wieder entziehen entziehen sie
damit nicht auch lothar wieler
öffentlich das vertrauen und ist das
heute vielleicht auch so der moment wo
sie sagen da haben wir einen fehler
gemacht und herr wüst die länder wollten
die entscheidung über den genesenden
status ja dem bundesrat überlassen
vielleicht können sie nochmal sagen
warum und ja wie ist es ausgegangen
heute
ich habe großes vertrauen dass er das
wirklich eine seit jahrzehnten wirklich
wichtige institution in unserem land ist
und herr villa hat wirklich eine ganz
verdienstvolle arbeit geleistet und
leistet sie unverändert die in dieser
pandemie von großer bedeutung ist und
das geht hier nicht um das lka soll und
darum dass wir uns als staat miteinander
verständigt haben dass angesichts der
großen bedeutung die das hat solche
festlegungen zu treffen die auf dem
gesetzlich
weitreichendsten niveau stattfinden
sollen und die beratung die gegenwärtig
vorbereitet werden bundestag so dass wir
jedenfalls die
delegation auf eine webseite
aufheben wollen und dadurch dass im
gesetz regeln und auch sicherstellen
dass beschränkungen die verborgenen
bürger dann wegen neuer erkenntnisse
zusätzlich eintreten könnten dass wir es
nicht hoffen und nicht annehmen aber das
ist ja das ist der hintergrund der frage
ist dass die dann nicht einfach
durch diese delegation diese verweisung
stattfinden kann sondern dass das dann
immer ein verfahren das in dem viele
beteiligt sind und das wird jetzt
gewährleistet an
glauben sie mir vorher ein satz zu sagen
der bürger wüst freut sich auf manche
einschränkungen die wegfällt politiker
wüst und gelb gilt auch für uns alle
drei hat auch die wohlhabenden gruppen
im blick
und ist deswegen auf achtsamkeit in der
öffnung bedacht zum thema genesen status
das war das alte verfahren das der
bundesrat zustimmungspflichtig war man
wollte ein schnelleres verfahren dieses
schnellere verfahren hat dann zu den
dingen geführt die in den letzten wochen
gesehen haben die über die auch alle
unglücklich sind
zwischenzeitlich hatte es noch eine
höchstrichterliche rechtsprechung dazu
gegeben so dass es jetzt den plan gibt
es im gesetz zu regeln
mir ist wichtig und das haben wir heute
auch festgehalten gemeinsam muss die
länderrechte dabei gewahrt werden das
werden wir jetzt immer sechs verfahren
auch beachten dass das in der
praktischen umsetzung nachher zu
gewährleistet ist
ich hatte genau ich habe zwei fragen
wenn sie erlauben einmal zur impfpflicht
die frage vielleicht auch an sie drei
gerichte aus der union gab es ja jetzt
erhebliche zweifel dass einer der
vorschläge also einer der anträge eine
mehrheit im parlament bekommen könnte
sehen sie das oder wie schätzen sie das
ein und an sie herr wüst sehen sie das
auch so teilen sie diese auffassung und
dann eine frage zum im krieg ist da wenn
ich das richtig sehe wurde das aus der
beschlussvorlage
rausgestrichen warum hat man sich dazu
entschieden vielen dank
wenn ich die zusammensetzung oder die
parteibücher der ministerpräsident und
ministerpräsidenten angucken dann sind
da welche
und spd von den grünen
der cdu und der csu
und alle sind gemeinsame meinung dass es
eine impfpflicht geben sollte
da sollten wir uns doch
bundeskanzler und 16 ministerpräsidenten
zusammen zutrauen dass wir dafür auch
eine mehrheit bekommen und dafür
politisch werben indem wir das jetzt
nicht so ein thema machen und den
üblichen politischen ränkespiele eine
rolle spielen und der eine guckt wird in
dem anderen am meisten das antun kann
sondern wie wir das tun dass an
verantwortung gegenüber
unseren bürgern und bürgern haben und
diese verantwortung und sagt dass wir
das noch das sehen ja auch die meisten
bürgern und bürgersohn deshalb gehe ich
einfach davon aus dass alle mit denen
ich heute zusammen geredet habe
mithelfen dass wir das hinkriegen da bin
ich ganz zuversichtlich was das register
betrifft ist das so dass das an der
diskussion darüber gibt ob man so etwas
grundsätzlich braucht also die frage
müssen wir irgendwie an der
elektronisch also eine daten absicherung
haben der impfung auf die man zugreifen
kann das ist eine diskussion die
technisch kompliziert ist und die auch
längere zeit in anspruch nimmt für die
frage impfpflicht müssen wir
möglichkeiten nutzen so sehe ich das
jedenfalls die wir haben ohne ein
solches register dass wir jetzt ja gar
nicht zu verfügung stellen können so
schnell und da gibt es ja
gesetzgebungsvorschläge die sich darüber
schon für sich selbst abschließende
gedanken gemacht haben ist ging also
auch ohne und darum ist das jetzt aus
der sicht jedenfalls eines teils der
wenigen die da diskutiert haben nicht
erforderlich gewesen das zu erwähnen
also die impfpflicht ist das richtige
darum soll es gehen
da fehlen dann für die frage
die experten haben heute die experten
gerade dort noch einmal vorgetragen dass
das impfen wichtig ist dass die impfung
die richtige art der immunisierung ist
auch mit blick auf den herbst unter lage
der dinge werden wir eine ausreichende
durchimpfung der bevölkerung ohne eine
impfpflicht nicht erreichen
das ist fakt was ist genauso fakt das
ist eine solche vielzahl von gruppen
anträgen gibt oder geben soll wenn ich
richtig im bilde bin gibt es mindestens
einen angekündigten noch nicht dass nach
lage der dinge im bundestag bisher keine
antrag einer dieser anträge eine
mehrheit er hat insofern ist die
schlichte feststellung richtig ich habe
für die unionsgeführten bundesländer im
vergangenen monat angeboten dass wir zu
gesprächen bereit sind und die unions
bundestagsfraktion hat das durch den
parlamentarischen geschäftsführer am
gestrigen tage auch noch einmal gemacht
wir sind nicht am ende der
meinungsfindung mehrheitsfindung im
deutschen bundestag
dann als nächstes andreas hinkel von
reuters
dankeschön der bundeskanzler ich wollte
noch mal zum basisschutz fragen sie
haben eben in ihrem eingangsstatement
vorsichtig gesagt sie werden sich dafür
verwenden dass die gesetzliche grundlage
geschaffen wird deswegen hatte ich ganz
gerne noch mal nachgefragt sind sie ganz
sicher oder haben sich die zusicherung
der fdp die ja mal von einem freedom day
gesprochen hatte der jetzt am
zwanzigsten
basisschutz danach noch gibt vielleicht
nicht in der form kommt haben sie die
zur sicherung ihres koalitionspartners
dass er das im gesetzgebungsverfahren
auch mitmacht und eine frage an die
beiden länder vertreter und drin
ist die neue phase die sie beschrieben
haben nicht eigentlich eine neue
abwägung zwischen mehrheits wünschen
nach lockerungen und minderheiten lasten
denn in dem papier das sie verabschiedet
haben wird ja selber erwähnt und der
expertenrats hatte hat das auch getan
dass die zahl der intensivpatienten über
60 wieder steigen wird also ist das
nicht eine seltsame gleichzeitigkeit
dass sie einerseits die schutzmaßnahmen
loben und sie gleichzeitig abbauen
wir müssen immer wissen wo wir stehen
wir haben jetzt reicht es den
vollständigen impfschutz wir heute
definiert wird 75 prozent der
bevölkerung haben oder die mindestens
zwei impfungen haben das ist schon ganz
schön viel die zahl derjenigen die
auffrischungsimpfung haben denn auch
ständig zu und wir wissen gleichzeitig
dass wir aber nicht da sind wo wir
hinkriegen kommen müssen andere länder
in europa haben eine quote liegt bei 85
oder noch mehr prozent
und ich habe gerade mit der dänischen
ministerpräsidenten getroffen gehabt die
hat eine impfquote für die über 60
jährigen die wenn ich mich richtig
erinnere 97 prozent oder sogar noch
etwas höher liegt und dort haben viele
von denen sogar
fast alle auch drei impfungen das ist
zum beispiel etwas was den markt das
sicherer macht im umgang mit möglichen
virus infektionsquellen sind noch auf
uns zukommen kann und deshalb bleibt wie
wir alle da ist betont haben und aber
auch diejenigen jetzt nicht an diesem
tisch sitzen sondern mit beraten haben
impfen die zentrale aufgabe die wir
haben impfen hilft die erste impfung
hilft schon die zweite impfung noch mehr
die dritte impfung am allermeisten und
das ist das was wir gerne versuchen zu
sagen wofür wir ganz intensiv werden und
wo wir auch nicht nachlassen dann wenn
jetzt der zwanzigste erreicht es dann
geht es weiter mit dieser aufgabe ich
sage ausdrücklich wir brauchen auch nach
dem zwanzigsten basisschutz darüber
besteht einvernehmen übrigens auch in
der regierung und in der
regierungskoalition also über die das
bundeskabinett 1 hinaus und wir werden
sicherstellen dass es eine gesetzgebung
gibt die rechtzeitig dann ermöglicht
dass dieser basis dieser basis maßnahmen
ergriffen werden können und geregelt
werden können und dass sie den ländern
und den wenigen die verantwortung haben
den landkreisen und den städten auch zur
verfügung steht die dinge die ihr
genannt sind halte ich alle für
erforderlich und ich bin sicher dass wir
ein gesetzgebungsverfahren zustande
bringen werden dass genau dieser
verantwortung gerecht wird es wird also
ein hoch effektiven basisschutz geben
mit gemeinsame beschlussfassung und
bundestag und bundesrat und das ist auch
gut so
das ist auch gut so das ist eine schöne
schluss satz den wir hier so aufgreifen
können oder scholz der bundeskanzler
über den weg in die freiheit mit
basisschutz also mit sicherheitsnetz
oder auch eine freiheit auf bewährung
wenn man so will der schüler ist bei uns
leiter der parlamentsredaktion seiner
einschätzung der hand das ist ganz
interessant weil man so ein
versicherungsbüro ding verwendet so als
ob man jetzt hier also den basistarif
eine haftpflichtversicherung abschließen
man hätte auch in die vollkasko nehmen
können aber nein wir nehmen jetzt
bewusst den basisschutz klingt irgendwie
verlässlich was damit gemeint ist dass
man eigentlich verbergen will dass man
in der ampel na ja ich will dich sagen
mist gebaut hat aber man hat die
epidemische lage abgeschafft wenn man
gesagt hat braucht man nicht mehr als so
martialisch wir sind die öffner wir sind
die liberalen dieser merkelsche
sicherheitskurs der in folge führen
wenig fortan musste man doch noch mal
harte maßnahmen beschließen hat sie dann
bis zum 19 märz beschlossen und jetzt
muss man sich eigentlich eingestehen na
gut dann brechen alle verordnungen weg
die die länder haben und man kann nicht
mehr reagieren also brauchen wir einen
weiteren werkzeugkasten und jetzt muss
man noch mal ein gesetz machen das
möchte nicht die bundesregierung machen
das ist auch so ein für feinschmecker
der parlamentarischen ordnung wenn so
ein streitpunkt also der die nicht die
bundesregierung möchte diesen
basisschutz vorliegen sondern sie möchte
gerne dass der bundestag irgend etwas in
der richtung beschließt aber man muss
dann schon noch mal ein neues gesetz
machen dass sozusagen die dritte
entscheidung zur verlängerung es ist ein
bisschen unelegant aber in dem ton wie
olaf scholz das vorträgt merkt das
glaube ich gar niemand
ist nicht auf den tisch gehauen wie
gestern in moskau jahrhundert jahres war
dazu unsere reporterin vor ort
bundeskanzler abend die dieses treffen
verfolgt hat ja dass friede freude
eierkuchen könnte man sagen und großer
einigkeit und wird von olaf scholz bei
jetzt beschworen tatsächlich gab es
durchaus knirschen hinter den kulissen
und es sind so kleine sätze wie zum
beispiel aus sicht der länder ist so ein
basisschutz möglich darüber wurde
gestritten kommt das rein ins papier
oder lässt man das raus aus dem papier
und hendrik wüst hat sich ja auch
bedankt dafür dass der bundeskanzler
scholz diesen katalog sozusagen sich
dafür verwenden will obwohl er
eigentlich nicht 100 prozent dahinter
steht also so persönlich wie gerade hier
beschrieben war es da offenbar nicht
das stimmt das habt ihr genau richtig
beschrieben tatsächlich versucht man im
nachhinein dann immer ein bisschen die
wogen zu glätten und es darzustellen
dass man nicht so lange diskutiert hätte
und sich schneller geeinigt hätte aber
tatsache ist es sind drei protokoll an
merken das heißt drei bundesländer haben
in diesem beschluss aus der
ministerpräsidenten konferenz gesagt wir
haben extra wünsche wir möchten wir
möchten die regeln bei uns im land
anders umsetzen als sie hier feststehen
wie das am ende geschehen wird das wird
man sehen also es in baden-württemberg
sachsen-anhalt unter anderem mit dabei
das wird sich dann entscheiden wenn die
länder ihre eigenen verordnungen
anpassen was denn in der kommenden woche
wahrscheinlich passiert und am ende des
tages hatten wir einen gipfel der zwar
sehr kurz genug gedauert hat das waren
insgesamt nur zwei stunden aber es gab
im vorfeld sehr viele sachen die man
versucht er zu erklären kommt dann im
register com kommt kein im register was
ist mit der impfpflicht was welche
länder finden sie gut welche finden sie
nicht gut also da waren sehr viele
themen die man versucht hat abzuräumen
und ich glaube was wir jetzt sehen mit
diesem beschluss ist man hat versucht
sich auf den kleinsten gemeinsamen
nenner zu einigen damit möglichst viele
sachen berücksichtigt berücksichtigt
werden konnten die den einzelnen ländern
wichtig waren und wir müssen tatsächlich
alle noch warten bis zum zwanzigsten
dritter also es dauert noch diese ganzen
fünf wochen und wie es danach weitergeht
entscheidet sich dann erst im bundestag
auch da ist wahnsinnig viel im schwange
wie geht es mit der masken pflicht
weiter was passiert in schulen wie lange
müssen kinder noch masken tragen wie
lange wird getestet das sind alles
sachen die jetzt noch offen sind ja es
waren dank für diese einordnung und dass
du alles für uns beobachtet hatte ralf
zusammenfassen noch mal ganz kurz die
einzelnen schritte
werden das war ja auch erstaunlich und
anders als bundeskanzlerin merkel die
also wirklich dezidiert die fakten
vorgetragen hat wohin olaf scholz mehr
die stimmung
vorgetragen hat also ganz kurz der erste
schritt zusammenkünfte für geimpfte und
genesene wieder ohne begrenzung dann am
4 märz 3g auch in der gastronomie wieder
und am 20 märz dann sollen die meisten
maßnahmen fallen letzter satz von dir
ein guter tag oder ein halb guter ein
gemischter halt gut da würde ich sagen
sachsen anhalt hat schon gesagt man
betrachtet das als orientierungsrahmen
so nach dem motto beschließt mal wir
machen unser und die regierende
bürgermeisterin aus berlin hat den
schönen das schöne wort gebraucht tanz
lustbarkeiten seien ab dem vierten märz
wieder erlaubt da dürfen wir uns schon
darauf freuen das kind schon ganz toll
tanz lustbarkeiten da freuen wir uns
drauf herzlichen dank für den besuch im
studio die einordnung der weg in die
freiheit meine damen und herren wir
haben ihnen heute hier gesehen und ich
ende mit den worten von nur schein dem
bauerntag erfinder ich sehe die
situation nicht mehr dramatisch den
würde man sich gerne anschließen einen
schönen tag noch